hey guys I'm Eric Voss and yes I know
I'm in a new space but it's still coming
together don't time to talk about it
because West world's amazing first
season has come to an epic conclusion
now spoiler alert if you haven't seen it
which shouldn't be necessary because you
were the one who clicked on a video
about the ending of a TV show so it's
your own fault but this season finale
revealed way more than I ever expected a
show produced by JJ Abrams do ever
reveal so we got four words new actually
violent narrative the meaning behind the
maze the voices in Dolores is head and
damn look at that the man in black is
actually William as an older man
I see that was the sound of thousands of
online conspiracy theorists climax scene
all at once now in case that free for a
loop I made another video breaking down
the convoluted timeline of Westworld
reordering the story in the exact
chronology definitely watch that but in
this video I'm gonna quickly explain
what the hell we just saw because let's
be honest Westworld threw a lot at us at
once and I think we all felt a bit like
Felix so let let let let let get started
okay first question what was ford's
master plan so all season long we saw
Ford preparing for his new secret
narrative digging up the city of
Escalante and repurposing hundreds of
hosts then in the final minutes it's a
total bloodbath
he has Dolores execute him exactly like
she executed Arnold and she and all the
other hosts opened fire on the rest of
the board members so why does he do this
Robert Ford has been a mysterious figure
throughout the season but one clear
drive for him was control his dream was
to be the god of his own world and total
control of all his creations and anytime
someone threatened that status quo they
were destroyed so that sense of order
made him an ideological opposite to
Arnold who was the co-creator of the
park Arnold's wanted the hosts to
achieve consciousness and destroy West
world and Ford the man of control
realized two things that he has lost
control over one he's an old man at the
end of his life and the end of his
career and the dillos corporation is
close to removing him from power and to
his old partner Arnold proved to be
right the host continued to gain
consciousness and Ford realized that the
hosts are the next stage of evolution
and they instantly had done
that this is his business via gun again
and after years and years of letting
these hosts evolve and change into fully
sentient beings and never really doing
anything to fix the problem board
realized that his time was short and
made his final move
one last narrative in which the hosts
violently overthrow their lesser evolved
predecessors humans something that he
for shadowed Juno what happened to the
nyan de toast banana we ate them okay so
Ford's master plan required several
steps one he created Bernard a host
modeled after his former partner Arnold
who's named by the way Bernard Lowe is
actually an anagram for Arnold Weber
which I felt like I was the last person
to discover anyway that way for it has
an assistant and a chief engineer that
he could trust with his secrets to Ford
built a backdoor into all hosts so he
could always control him
three he spent decades allowing
consciousness to spring up in the host
organically simply wiping their memories
and letting the problem reach a point of
no return for after years and years of
letting Sizemore take care of the
narratives Ford suddenly in her fears
then disrupted all the pre-existing
narratives to justify building his new
secret narrative five he secretly
changed the hosts prime directives
making them potentially dangerous to
humans and when Elsie discovers this he
sends Bernard to kill her or maybe just
silence her we'll talk about that later
six when Teresa tried to steal the host
code for Delos and circumvent board
he used Bernard to kill her as well as
cover up the death and their love affair
seven he updated Maeve so that she could
wake herself up from sleep and believe
that she has free will leading to her
plan to escape with feelings eight Ford
exploited the back door to stop Bernard
from killing them out of anger however
he also ensured that the bullet only
grazed Bernards cranial shield so that
he could quickly be brought back and
interact with Maeve as part of the
narrative that he wrote for her that way
she could go out into the outside world
and engage in mainland infiltration
which I'll talk about in a bit nine Ford
gave Dolores one final push to achieve
full consciousness knowing that she
would use her free will to enact her
previous massacre in hopes of freeing
herself and ten reveal the final
narrative as the first step in a violent
overthrow assuring in the next stage of
evolution now
notice some affords final words votes on
Beethoven and Chopin never died
they simply became music now on a
literal level he's referring to his own
final opus this new narrative that he's
built that will change the world
but some people are thinking that Ford
may also be hinting that he built a
hosts version of himself and that this
Ford may actually just be a host or this
is the real Ford and there's another
host version of them somewhere that's
ready to carry on his legacy
so that Ford can live on through his
life's work these hosts and this could
be plausible considering board does have
a secret lab where he built Bernard and
could plausibly make new artificial
hosts he also has a huge ego I could see
him doing this but I also don't really
know because seeing Ford like show up
and walk around next season it would
kind of take away the power of this
perfect farewell but I could see him
coming back like in a memory or in a
voice form like Arnold did haunting the
hosts from beyond the grave either way
if any Hopkins did tweet that he's
enjoyed working on the show implying
that his work is done on it so we'll see
if he comes back in season 2 now let's
move on to another mystery this episode
dealt with what is the maze so after a
season of the maze patterns showing up
everywhere and people bringing it up in
conversation this finale revealed
exactly what the maze is so as explained
by Arnold to Dolores the maze is a
metaphor for the journey a host takes to
achieve true consciousness so initially
Arnold imagined this journey as a
pyramid with different layers the bottom
one being memory because humans need to
remember things to learn from them and
then improvisation because humans tend
to deviate from their routine and then
on top of that self-interest because
humans make decisions to protect in
further themselves but Arnold realized
that consciousness isn't a journey
upward
but a journey inward so he reimagined
these from layers of a pyramid to
concentric layers of a circular maze
which was modeled on a children's toy
belonging to Arnold Sun in which it
would be difficult to navigate your way
into the center just like it's difficult
for the human mind to understand its
true nature so in other words the maze
is not a physical place hidden somewhere
in West world like a huge hedge maze or
something and this isn't something that
William can use this is a metaphor
describing how hosts can become
conscious they learn to remember they
learn to improvise they learn to act in
self-interest and the final key isn't a
voice from above it's a voice from
within and notice how forward repeated
that idea later when describing the
brain shape hidden in Michelangelo's
paintings it took five hundred years for
someone to notice something hidden in
plain sight as dr. who noticed the shape
of the human brain message being that
the divine gift does not come from this
shows that board knows everything Arnold
did and he's been building on his work
now you may remember Arnold's pyramid
theory was first introduced back in
Episode three and by the way looking
back now I love how the show visually
foreshadowed the circular design by for
drawing this pyramid in a circle that
was previously on the blackboard but
there's a key difference with fourth
pyramid Arnold only had three layers but
Ford added a fourth layer saying it was
the last step of consciousness and at
the end of this episode Ford tells
Bernard what that final component is
thing that led the host to throw
wakening suffering pain that the world
is not as she wanted to be the Ford
realized that suffering is a key part of
the human experience the hosts need to
feel emotional pain to be truly
conscious in the way humans are so
apparently if you've never suffered
you're not human which is a huge relief
because all I do is suffer so Arnold saw
the lorises true consciousness when she
talked about the grief over losing her
parents and William saw Mavis true
consciousness when he killed her
daughter that suffering is why Ford made
Dolores travel on this tortuous journey
over and over he wanted to prime her
with enough suffering to achieve
consciousness now how did the host get
to that
the maze that's the purpose of the
reveries remember reveries are the
behavioral responses linked to specific
memories everyone attributed them to
Ford but they were actually a creation
by Arnold now they were supposed to be
simple behaviors that made the host more
lifelike but they caused some to
malfunction and that's because Arnold's
real purpose for the reveries was to
create a link between the layers of the
maze letting the host build on each
layer and move inward he endowed them
first with memory and the reverie caused
that to spill over into improvisation
which would lead to acting and
self-interest and later result in
suffering basically guiding each host
deeper into their own mental maze until
they reached the center ok so related to
the maze is another mystery what are the
voices in Dolores is mine
so the finale episodes title is the
bicameral mind which takes us back again
to that scene in episode 3 he based it
on the theory of consciousness called
the bicameral mind
Ford explains to Arnold that the theory
of the bicameral mind is to try to give
the host consciousness with external
voice commands assuming that the host
would hear them as an inner monologue
and eventually their own thoughts would
take over and even though he says that
they abandon that plan this is exactly
what we see happened to Dolores in this
season she receives several mysterious
voice commands over the course of the
episodes like when she shoots rebus
and when she's on the run so early in
the finale Dolores still doesn't
understand the final step do you
understand now Dolores what the center
represents whose voice I've been wanting
you to hear and try but I don't
understand but later in the episode when
she reaches full consciousness she
finally understands do you know now who
you've been talking to whose voice
you've been hearing Oh
so Dolores his own independent thoughts
have now taken over now the show used
some really interesting audio tricks
here so if you listen carefully to the
earlier instances the speaker is really
hard to make out it sounds like a mix of
several characters but in this final
instance the audio separates the mix so
that we hear each of the voices one at a
time first Arnold oh then Ford and then
finally Dolores this is a really cool
way to show that the voice commands were
originally created for Dolores by Arnold
perpetuated by Ford and now assumed by
Dolores herself okay another question
what is the meaning of the quote these
violent delights have violent ends so
remember this is a quote Abernathy
whispered to Dolores in the first
episode who then shared it with Maeve
and then in the finale we learned that
this was Arnold's final words before he
had Dolores execute him and then right
before Dolores repeats the behavior with
Ford Barnard repeats it so what does
this mean well it's established that
Abernathy used to be a professor who
knew Shakespeare and these violent
delights have violent ends is from Romeo
and Juliet act 2 scene 6 when Friar
Laurence says the line to Romeo to warn
him that a reckless dangerous romance
will end the same way and this ends up
being a theme for West world as a whole
that the blissfully violent delights
that people take part in have unforeseen
consequences particularly in this case a
judgement day where the recipients of
violence return the favor and it was
awesome to see the season book end with
this quote to deliver on that promise so
spectacularly ok moving on what happens
to made so Maeve learns
finale that her whole Awakening and plan
to escape was actually just an elaborate
narrative scripted by Ford if you look
closely at Bernards tablet screen
outlining her narrative can actually see
what the final step is mainland
infiltration so it seems that Board's
plan was for her to escape West world
and spread the host revolution to the
outside world but I also think there was
a more directly practical purpose behind
maids narrative really to create a
diversion drawing all the park security
to battle with Hector and arms this who
are two of the deadliest gunslingers in
the part this would make it tougher for
the security to help fight against the
hosts as they try to take over at the
gala but in the last second on the train
Maeve sees a woman with her daughter and
she's reminded of her host daughter
losing her daughter was her Keystone
memory that all of her reveries are
linked back to that initially sent her
deeper into her own maze felix found out
for me that her daughter's located in
park one sector fifteen zone three and
maid decides to go off-script even
though she had previously assumed that
she was already going off script that
defiance to ford's narrative shows
Maeve's true consciousness and knowing
that everything else her made us been
pre scripted by Ford this may be the
first time we see may truly sentient and
going into season two when everyone's a
little bit evil Maeve may be the last
protagonist on this show that we really
root for making Dolores possibly the new
antagonist and that note from Felix
leads me to another big mystery what is
samurai world so an interesting thing
about that note is that it says park1 as
in there are other parts and sure enough
as Maeve tries to escape with Felix
Hector and Armistice they enter another
part of the complex marked with this SW
logo filled with all these samurai hosts
so obviously this sets up season two to
maybe explore other parts of the park
and it makes sense that if one
historical time period existed for an
escapist theme park that there would be
alternatives for people who just you
know aren't into the Old West and in the
1973 West world that this series is
loosely based on there actually were
other zones of the park besides West
world medieval world and Roman world
there's also a sequel that expanded them
to future world and spa world I don't
know uh sounds like the engineers got a
little lazy on that one so I'm not sure
if this means season 2 will explore
samurai world in particular or if it's
just meant to open up the possibility
that tons of other worlds exist and
only one last question from the finale
are there any humans left alive in the
park so this will be a big question
going into season two obviously William
is left alive clementines shot him in
the arm as the host surrounded the gala
and I think that was intentional forward
respected William and he appreciated him
keeping him financially solvent for all
the years of the part I don't think he
wanted this to be a kill shot just a
warning shot to show him that the hosts
are now dangerous and to give him the
gift of the exact true life-or-death
game that William had longed for but
there are two other loose threads here
so one is Stubbs who we saw get tackled
by the ghost nation natives in Episode
nine that guy is pretty tough and the
fact that we didn't see is like skull
gets smashed makes me think that we'll
see him again
the other is LC so it was simply implied
that Bernard silenced her again we just
saw her get pulled back at a headlock
like no blood no corpse also the show's
promotional site for the Telus
corporation posted a mysterious code
that when you decode it shows Elsie's
coordinates in the park and an audio
file that sounds a lot like her voice
okay now if you were curious about
William being revealed as a man in black
and how that affects the show's
complicated timeline definitely check
out my other Westworld video I get into
all that stuff also if you're interested
in some deeper predictions for Westworld
season 2 I highly recommend you go watch
a video by our old buddy Phillip Malina
over at SourceFed nerd the link is in
the description it's amazing I miss that
guy he's like the Ford to my Barnard
wait a minute ok thanks for watching and
let me know what you think in the
comments please hit like and subscribe
to new rockstars and share this video
with your friends you can also
contribute to us on patreon thank you so
much all of our current patrons
including our newest patron Matthew
solve us thank you so much Matthew if
you aren't currently a patron we'd love
your support you can hit me up on
twitter at EA box with any thoughts or
theories that you have about Westworld
seriously I love this show I look
forward to talking about it for the
foreseeable future you can also follow
new rock stars on Twitter at new rock
stars for updates on when our videos are
coming out okay thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you